elle est de ceux qui travaillent dans
l'ombre n'est liquetti fait partie des
petites mains qui participent à la
confection d'un film monteuse de cinéma
depuis de nombreuses années elle a
remporté le César 2022 du meilleur
montage pour le film Annette de Léo
Carax et s'est accompagné de la fameuse
statuette qu'elle est revenue dans son
ancien lycée à Mantes-la-Jolie face à la
nouvelle génération elle a mis en
lumière ce métier encore assez méconnu
j'ai essayé de trouver des photos j'ai
très peu de photos de moi dans une salle
de montage c'est quelque chose qu'on
confirme pas c'est pas c'est quelque
chose on comprend pas en photo c'est
c'est même prendre des photos de sol
démontage on sait jamais où se mette etc
c'est et puis c'est un moment intime le
montage c'est un moment intime on est on
est trois dans une salle de montage et
un réalisateur la matière et le menteur
avec qui veut travailler c'est différent
à chaque fois que s'adapter même si
maintenant par Internet on s'est un peu
plus de choses qu'à mon époque
c'est quand même un métier assez
mystérieux très c'est très très
difficile d'en parler de ce métier ça ça
relève de beaucoup de choses et peu de
gens savent à quoi ça consiste Nelly a
été invité dans le cadre d'un César à
l'école un dispositif éducatif et
artistique créé par l'association un
artiste à l'école en collaboration avec
l'Académie des Césars leur mission
rendre accessible la culture aux jeunes
en faisant revenir des artistes
césarisés dans leur ancien établissement
scolaire on travaille avec les
professeurs qui sont inscrits on fournit
un dossier pédagogique et quelques
ressources autour de l'intervenant le
jour J on revient on revisite un peu
l'établissement pour ramener les
souvenirs à l'intervenant et puis il y a
après c'est un échange basé sur les
questions des élèves le but c'est qu'il
soit vraiment plutôt dans l'action
de la pellicule ou numérique vous l'avez
pris comment vous c'était dur ou ouais
des moments de transmission qui
éveillent la curiosité des élèves
projet pendant des heures et des heures
monteur c'est incroyable ça renforce un
peu le lien parce que on se dit c'est
des millions un peu on peut pas y aller
accéder tout ça alors que là si il
vienne jusqu'ici bah c'est
mais d'expérience où on peut tenir des
Césars des trucs comme ça c'est
intéressant et surtout de faire savoir
que par exemple les quetsches elle était
là Saint-Exupéry mais on peut dire que
bah peut-être ça peut nous arriver à
nous et ça nous donne un peu une
confiance près de 17000 élèves partout
en France ont pu bénéficier de ce
dispositif depuis sa création en 2012 de
quoi susciter plusieurs vocations